あとセクション２つぐらいありますけど
次に考えてみるのは この自己破壊っていうのはこの魔法にかけられたような感じなんですよ
だから大好きという単語を使ったんですけど
英語から考えればこれ変えた方がいいなと思ったんですけど
で 自己破壊は魔力的ですと
好きで好んで堕落するんですよ
人間っていうのは しかし
他人のせいにするんです
英語で言えばそういうふうに言えるんです
で 次のポイントは 人は堕落したり
精神的に病気になったり
いろいろありますね そういうことを訴えたりもしますよ
なんとか幸せになりたいとか
でも協力してもなれないんですね
医者が悪い あなたの教え方が悪いとか何とか言うんですね
いつでも他人が悪いんです
それが本人気づいてないんですけど
堕落すること 自己破壊っていうのは魔法にかけられたような感じで
もう好きでたまらないんですね
妄想にふける二型 同じことを繰り返しですから
難しくはないと思います
絵は論理 哲学 データなどに基づいて思考にふける人がいる
しかし その人は科学的な理論を発見したり
哲学思考を発見したり
社会が驚くアイデアを作ったりもする
妄想にふけってますけど
タイプはそんなもんなんですね
役に立つか否かは別として
小説家などもいます 芸術
小説 全部妄想家なんですよ
科学者も相当に妄想するんですよ
しかし そういう人々の違うところは
ただ単に妄想だけではなくて
たとえ空想であっても
いろいろデータで そこはなんとか裏付けすぎてみようかなと思ったり
それから本を書いたり
いろんなことをしたりします
小説というのは明らかに妄想でしょうね
しかし この妄想が本物のごとくいかに見せかけるのかとということに挑戦するんです
だから実際のデータを書くんです
何かの場面を説明すると
本当にそういうその場面なんです
例えば小説で出てくる一人の役が精神的に病気で
それで病名はこれであると
その場合は病名やら症状やら与える薬のリストやら
もういろいろデータのリストも書くんです
全部本物です それは しかし
人は全く嘘なんです 読む人が確かにこの人は病気だと何か錯覚するだけで
そんな人は存在もしませんだけど
そういうわけで この妄想家というか
芸術家 小説家 みんなそうやっても何か作り出しますよ
それが社会に役に立つか立たないかと
小説読んで何か役に立つかというとちょっと疑問なんですけど
まあ最低本人の役にでも立ってるでしょうね
例えば科学発明発展で人間が役に立っているのかというと
これはちょっと一貫しては言えないことで
しかし 人生を苦労することには変わりがありません
しかし そういう人々にしても
生きることは大変苦しいんですよ
楽じゃないんです 小説を書くことはそう簡単楽じゃないんです
結構研究しなくちゃいけないんです
研究したっても 研究で論文書けばいいでしょう
論文は書きません 小説を書くんです
大変苦しいんです だから妄想するんだから
いろんなことをね 酒に依存するは
タバコに依存するは いろいろ問題も起こしたりします
B のタイプはね 感情の力で妄想にふける人もいる
彼らは妄想の渦巻きから抜けられません
概念のループを作って
どこまででも妄想を回転する
感情が増幅して病気になる
罪を犯す 自己破壊に陥る
普通の人間は A と B が混じって妄想するんです
これ  A と B と言ったら極端的な例で
一般人というのは大体 A と B が混じっているんですね
だからこの俺 好きでやってますよ
嫌で妄想させることはできないですよね
そういうことで まあ一応苦しみに依存するんですね
あのB型は 例えば嫉妬の妄想ができていると苦しいでしょうね
しかし ずっと嫉妬するんですね
怒り 嫉妬 落ち込みで刺激を感じるんですよ
人を憎むことで刺激を感じる
北朝鮮がもう日本を憎むことですごい刺激を感じて国を治めているんです
何の関係もないの ただ単に怒りで狂ってるだけで
また自信が失ったら 闇雲に言い訳を探すんです
時々人々が自信がなくなっちゃうんですよ
で これいつ自信がなくなるかわからない
時々小学校の時は自信があるんだけど
中学に入った途端自信がなくなったりする場合もあるし
中学までうまくいったんですけど
高校の時は自信がなくなったっていうこともあるし
大学で自信がなくなって大学を辞める場合もあるし
大学もなんとかうまくいって
会社に入ったところで途中でダメになる場合もあります
これは自信というものは何やってる？別に考えなくちゃいけないんですけど
まあ一昨日夜ある人に言いましたけどね
まあこれで自信がないでしょ
あなたにはと もうだから他の人々をやっていることできないでしょうと
そしたら私ははっきりあんた安倍さん知ってますか？と
安倍さん誰で安倍さんという人がいます
有名な人は と言ったら
総理ですか？そうですけど
知ってますか？と 知ってますと
あの人に自信があると思いますかと
よく顔を見てください
テレビで と言ったら やっぱりなんか自信なさそうで
そうですよと 自信があってあんな仕事できませんよと
だから人は日本の国で一番トップにもなってますけど
いまだに自信がないんだよと
誰にも自信があって頑張ってるわけじゃないんです
だから妄想する連中はもう自信探すんですよ
そんなのあるわけないでしょ
どこにも 本当に頑張って成功する人々には
ひとかけらも自信がないんです
ただ もうやるべきことをやるだけで
いろんなことにうまくいってなかったら
まあうまくいかなかった
もう初めから別にうまくいくとは思ってなかったし
自信はなかったしね だから落ち込まないんです
それで安倍さんが次の選挙で負けたら自信がなくなって落ち込むと思いますかね
何か言い訳してまた立ち直りますよ
選挙に出たら自信がないんですよ
ですから この自信がなくなって精神的に病気になった人に自信をつけてあげようと
お医者さんがやることは無駄なんです
とことん自信を壊した方がいいんです
で 科学の世界でも お医者さんが薬を推薦するときでも
ぴったし自信があるわけじゃないんですよ
だからまあ自信がない世界で生きているんです
なのにこの頭が悪い人はね
そこを問題に出すんですよ
そこで頭の悪い他の人々も自信をつけてあげようと
大丈夫 大丈夫といろんなことを言ったりして
これは解決しません とにかく自信がなくなったと思った人は
このやみくもに言い訳だけするんですよ
言い訳って何なのかというと
一番簡単に妄想にふけって病気になるんです
精神的に だから会社で自信がなくなったら
すぐその人何するんですかね
会社を辞めて家に引きこもるでしょ
それであれは嘘になったり
自分で作るんです 本人気づかないだけで
それからまあ言い訳はまあもう奥さんが怒るんだったら
さらに病気をひどくするんです
体が震えたり 人が来たっても
もうお前行きなさいと言って
自分が部屋のドアをかけて中にいたりとか
そうすると奥さんもやっぱり旦那がすごく病気で困ったなとかね
親切にしちゃうんですね
そうやってこのまんまと人に乗ろうとしているんですよ
自信がないということが言い訳にして
だからその人にはそうやって言い訳して引きこもることしか道が見当たらないんですね
だからそこを直そうと思っちゃうと大嫌いです
直したらまた学校にあるいは会社に行かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
会社クビになったら別な仕事探さなくちゃあかんでしょうに
これはもうやりたくないんです
だからこの妄想から出てくる病気っていうのは
ものすごいタチが悪いんですよ
だから一番本人が苦しいんだから訴えるんですよ
だからお医者さんのところにも
カウンセラーのところにも
いろんなところに行く
行って訴えたら 向こう側もやっぱりなんとかしてあげなくちゃあかんでしょうに
でも聞かないんだから
これって迷惑もいいところなんですね
妄想で精神病になることで
自分のプライドを守りつつ逃げるんです
あれでプライドを守ってます
私は病気だからもう仕事はできない
平気で言うんです それでものすごくプライドですよ
だけど あんたそういう仕事がないから
家の仕事でもやったらどうですかとある人に聞いたんです
あんたのお母さんが仕事してるでしょうにと
だったらあんた料理作ったら家のことそういう仕事お母さん助かるで
何のことを言うんですか？私は病気でしょうに
だったら食って寝なさい
それもしなくて 食べ物はあれやこれやとかね
台所で音を立てるんだとかね
これは気に入らんとか
そこまで言うんです だからまあ病気というと
そういうすごいことになりますよ
あるいは自分のプライドを守っているつもりです
病気を言い訳にして この人も徹底的に自分の症状に依存するんですよ
だからこの B型の人は
現実逃避するために病気で逃げて病気に依存するんですよ
病気に依存してもいいわけないでしょうに
病気は病気だから 精神的な病気は肉体的病気よりもひどいんだから
だから明らかに不幸でしょうし
人生ダメになるでしょうし
でもやめられないということは
それが唯一の藁にすがるような感じで
それ藁なんですね すがっている
だから一番爆発するのは自信が失った時なんですよ
だから 子供は元気で明るくなって
自信満々で頑張っている時でも
とことんいじめた方がいいんですよ
いわゆる自信というのは
お前いい加減な自信を持つんじゃないよとかね
あんた自信がありすぎやとかね
そんな甘くないんだよと
失敗もするんだよとかね
元気な時言うと もうやっぱり
あ そうか そうかと言って聞き聞いて
それですごく大人になるんです
それで何かにぶつけたら
まあお母さんも言っちゃったんだから甘くないんだよと
結構やられるんだと いじめられるんだよと言ったんだから
ということでもう頑張れます
暗い思考はなかなか止められないのですね
ですから 暗い思考に入ったら
これ止められないんです
しかし やがて地獄に落ちる羽目になります
いわゆるもうどんな意味でもいいんですよ
地獄という単語の理解は
確実に地獄に落ちるという意味でもいいんです
なぜならば 暗い思考は罪ですからね
俗世間的に地獄に落ちますよと言ったっても
落ちるようでもいいんですけど
そういうことになります
はい